[оплески]
євроінтеграція цивілізаційний вибив
україни а відведення кросу частиною
головний аліментів протезиста дарував
кас українських реформ так заявляла
українсько влада алли що нас правді
лається і документ на сотні store ніг
за них чуманів
євросоюз став головним торгували їм
партнером України при всіх кладовищі
економічну рецесії це вино на
донбасі хоча українським вирудникам і
шлюбу та інвестицій з приватних
технологій та стандарті в яскравості
заданим та мін економіки експорт до школи
вам а слів з однією з у 153 рази
отримавши у 52 за галон 40 високі слова
експорту україни нині продаємо до євросоюзу
відразу милу в ножах уроку на витя що ми
бачимо там два з половиною уроки колег 9
автомобіль торги війни та преференції
тут немає і повноцінний за виконавцем
переорієнтації українського бізнесу на
ринок Європейського Союзу і тут
немає і модернізацію таким чином, ніж з
таку труби ти масштабну експансію
української продукції з точки за раму
каже аналітик поки знаки кієса раз у
воріт протягла український бізнес
розумівши вин я дістати не конкурент usb
можна і спеціально до засідання ради
обговорити і україною а у брюсселі
єврокомісія вперше прийдуть його ладу
павич сотню його кун вони виродки зубного
боці київ похвалили за глибоке це
Безпрецедентний реформи сімшова
значилося що реформа частки прямих
інвестицій мало
на тому місці багата правова це судновий
на передачі влади за приціл у брюсселі
дізнався і Миколай даси український ульотний
buff настільки серйозно на вашу то ванній
на реформи ми стали сувій іншим
вірної роботи української влади на 2
чай але складних обставлений з прочитаних
конфліктом на сході України
незаконну анексію криму та севастополя
сьогодні ми підписали документ праві
справами 104 мільйони євро на комплексну
форму система державного управління
сферою форм програм за голом за
результатом і засідання ради про суть батьків
україна 3 мало мільярд євро фінансової
допомога і всі місяці на реформи у porsche
ерік погнути або
працюю води прошу частиною завалений
проблеми з дефекацією збоку нідерландів
antiche проблема не давала забувати та
про саму воду та spoon вікон та українську
і низка людей сьогодні на нас потребах
ти така ситуація кабула там у до
військових годин у Росії уколи поїхати в
москву china кислоти бандеролі москву
ще вид права на демонтаж м'язів було так
найлегша київ-житомир обидва в чорниці та
нам треба досі ти такої ситуації там
за шви лісабоном берліном до 2025 року
україна моя implement уват і моя ж 350
актив європейського закону зручності
зачитування впорядкованим планом до того часу
україна травні до курячого змінитеся а так
та активу вимагала революції гнусик що
троє рок і тому патча лося найсуворіші
питу сад і
угоду про асоціацію з